now who doesn't love the pump and
pageantry of festivals well it's not any
different in Ghana when it comes to the
annual Dunbar Festival it brings people
aligned to the traditional Kingdom
together to reflect on their origin and
how to confront Social Challenges it's
considered the most widely celebrated in
the northern part of the country theater
views Maxwell souk joined the climax of
the celebration in nalarugu where it's
time for people to come together put on
their dancing shoes and celebrate their
ancient line of royalty it stretches all
the way back to the nagbeiwa the famous
pasting who oral history says was the
founder of Five Kingdoms in West Africa
generation and excitement at the Navy
Palace descendants of the first king
najiwa are dancing to the readings from
indigenous Realms tradition says that
the kingdom of was founded back in the
13th century
the current king of Mount princes
II has reigned since 2004. his Palace
eldest knows all about the tradition
the democracies are celebrating
Festival were just in the celebration
mood which comes on annually damper
means shake your body shake your body
that is what we mean by Dumba man
presses
first they came from the child in
zamfara in Northern Nigeria so it is The
Descendants
who celebrate this Dumba Festival
dancing with Spears like this is an
important part of the festival
it is to inform enemies about the
standing army protecting the king
man program is one of the kingdoms that
were established through war and
Conquest in West Africa it straight
across Northern Ghana into neighboring
countries
the king of manpro
has some of his subjects in Burkina Faso
in Togo across some regions in
the country Ghana in those days the
whole kingdom was just ruled by the king
of manpro traditional kingdoms like this
were affected by the partitioning of
Africa during the colonial era which
left many success straddling the borders
drawn by the European Invaders
for those who flock here the festival is
an opportunity to connect their
pre-colonial past
a once to know our culture
culture is our pride
for Memorial Kingdom the joy is very
massive as you can see everyone around
is very excited he's offering us the
opportunity to socialize for the first
time after the recovery restrictions if
all people from around the kingdom are
gathering today to celebrate
divisional chips and skin by the king
must also show their honor through a
special Dumber dance in the full glare
of the public
there are some Chiefs some some people
and skin they will go back to their
communities and will never come back to
the King again so it is this time that
all of them will come have to come back
and pay homage to the nigeri
then your exhibit their dancing skills
whilst the manprogo kingdom is
confronted with modern day challenges
water remains solid is the desire to
preserve their Heritage through the
Festival